there's no doubt republicanism on the
market there are two things that are
very much at odds but again I think
that's just the world we live in we live
in a very changing space and I think
that those of us in political leadership
need to have the confidence from our own
background it doesn't
um our own standpoint doesn't diminish
my republicanism to attend the
coronation of the king to be respectful
to those people here over British
identity who look their political
agencies is pointed that way so I just
think that at these moments in these
junctures it's really really important
that we are confident enough on our own
skin to be able to take initiatives like
this and actually to do something that
demonstrates that I will be first I'm
first Minister for all and someone who
as an Irish Republican can represent um
everybody in our community